depuis le 22 septembre la Foire
Internationale de Chatou et de retour
sur l'île des Impressionnistes la plus
ancienne foire de France revient pour
une 105e édition Rémi Machard bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le président du snoo
GA le comité organisateur de la foire de
Chatou également exposant on imagine que
vous attendiez ce retour avec impatience
on attend toujours la poire de Chatou
avec impatience c'est un grand
rendez-vous pour les professionnels qui
viennent de la France entière qui
viennent parfois de l'étranger des
Belges des Italiens et puis les
visiteurs aussi attendent le retour de
cette événement avec impatience de
découvrir ces visiteurs pendant la
dizaine de jours on se tient la foire
alors la foire de Chatou c'est vraiment
l'expression de toutes les ambiances
autour de que peuvent présenter les
professionnels tous les tous les
courants artistiques de l'Antiquité
jusqu'au vintage donc vous pourrez
rencontrer vraiment toutes les grands
courants artistiques
de notre histoire et de notre culture
une des forces de la foire c'est tout ce
qui a d'exposer ici c'est une foire qui
se tient pour la 105ème édition c'est un
événement historique qu'est-ce qui fait
que ça continue de marcher dans le temps
c'est une institution et puis comme je
vous l'ai dit les professionnels ont
besoin de s'exprimer de présenter
leur leurs œuvres leur belle pièce leur
beaux objets et puis de rencontrer le
public c'est ça le succès de Chatou
c'est une ambiance particulière qui qui
est très attendu et qui est nécessaire à
notre profession et qui est pour
laquelle le public est en attente vous
personnellement en tant que exposant
qu'est-ce qu'elle représente cette foire
de Chatou ouais c'est un moment
important dans l'année
à l'automne et au printemps ce sont deux
grands rendez-vous et bien sûr comme
comme les autres professionnels je
réserve des pièces exclusivement pour la
Foire de château on a demandé aux
exposants de la force que représenter la
foire de chatouche vous propose qu'on
les écoute c'est le rendez-vous pour
nous les marchands deux fois par an on
est content tous se retrouver ici afin
de chatouilles il y a une super ambiance
pour moi déjà c'est des souvenirs aussi
un peu d'enfance parce que je venais là
plus petit avec mes parents je suis venu
là quand j'étais aussi toujours
collectionneur maintenant je suis
marchand pour moi c'est beaucoup de
choses on va dire la force du château
mais il y a surtout quelque chose
d'intéressant c'est que il y a de moins
en moins de fois aussi en région
parisienne aux antiquaires donc ça
permet de concentrer aussi un certain
nombre de personnes plus joli
rendez-vous qu'on puisse trouver
qui est bi annuel et qui en plus est
local pour moi parce que je suis 30
minutes d'ici à Crespières donc sans
boutique mais donc justement la foire
c'est l'occasion de montrer un petit peu
tout ce qu'on a dans la maison alors
Rémy machin on retrouve cette année
encore les exposants historiques il y a
également des nouveaux exposants tous
les ans oui chaque année il y a il y a
un renouvellement
d'une partie des exposants alors vous
savez la foire de Chatou c'est c'est un
événement qui a attendu par les
professionnels et donc il y a des gens
qui sont là depuis vraiment la toute
première édition on a des anciens qui ne
peuvent pas se se passer de l'ambiance
festive de Chatou et puis pour une autre
catégorie
d'exposants c'est à dire les plus jeunes
c'est un challenge de de réussir à
exposer à la fois de Chatou et cette
année en particulier nous avons de très
jeunes exposants et nous sont très fier
puisque le SNCAO vient de créer le prix
Marcus donc le prix Marcus c'est le prix
du jeûne marchant acteur du patrimoine
que nous organisons sous le parrainage
de Stéphane Bern et qu'il sera remis au
mois de décembre
au lauréat et il y a quelques lauréats
qui sont ici présents et puis il y a des
jeux de marchands pour lesquels c'est la
première édition en termes de tranche
d'âge vous avez une idée du plus jeune
du plus vieux dans les marchands je
crois que ça va de 25 ans à
25 6 7 ans voilà oui c'est très large
finalement les objets qu'on retrouve
aussi il y a de nombreuses objets
d'exception est-ce qu'il y en a qui ont
particulièrement attiré votre attention
alors il y en a plein on les a vu mais
est-ce qu'il y en a quelques-uns qui ont
plus attiré votre attention écoutez il y
a toujours tellement de
une petite surprise de beaux objets que
je ne pouvais pas me focaliser sur un
seul plein d'objets on l'a compris il y
a déjà eu des ventes exceptionnelles
bien sûr il y en a tous les ans dans les
objets dans les œuvres d'art dans le
mobilier il y a du mobilier absolument
exceptionnel de tous les âges
de tous les styles oui oui il y a eu des
belles ventes qui se sont déjà passés ce
week-end et mais rassurez-vous il y a
encore énormément de choses à découvrir
énormément de choses qui qui attendent
une nouvelle maison vous qui connaissez
très bien la foire comment est-ce qu'on
fait des bonnes affaires de façon
générale sur la foire on ne peut faire
que des bonnes affaires vous savez j'ai
une formule qui dit que la le marché de
l'Antiquité le marché de l'art chez nous
à Chatou c'est la première classe au
prix de la seconde donc il faut savoir
que chaque objet par rapport à sa valeur
intrinsèque finalement est un prix très
bas alors il y a des experts qui sont
présents sur la foire d'une pape d'une
part pour contrôler ce qui est exposé
mais aussi pour aider les acheteurs
c'est ça c'est exactement ça alors cette
année nous avons un collège de cinq
experts un expert généraliste en bijoux
en art tribal en art contemporain ce qui
fait que ces experts sont à la
disposition du public dans un premier
temps il renseigne les marchands il
clarifie les descriptions et puis
pendant toute la durée de la foi ils
sont à la disposition du public et moi
je conseille de faire appel à l'expert
ou aux experts
avant de prendre une décision pour un
gros achat alors la foire de Chatou ça
fait le plaisir des chineur des
passionnés d'art mais c'est aussi
destiné aux simples curieux qui ont
envie de découvrir bien sûr la de Chatou
c'est un musée assez Louvet donc on
vient à Chatou aussi pour se cultiver
pour acquérir des connaissances
d'ailleurs la plus grande partie de
notre profession consiste à transmettre
bien sûr du patrimoine mais également
des connaissances leur Rémi machad
dernière question pour ceux qui ne sont
pas encore décidés à avoir franchi les
portes de la Foire des chatons pourquoi
il faut venir il faut venir parce que
c'est un lieu magique on peut avoir le
syndrome de Florence on peut
se régaler les yeux on peut acquérir de
très belles choses ou de choses simples
mais belle et authentique pour
agrémenter son intérieur merci Rémi
Machard d'avoir été avec nous d'avoir
répondu à nos questions merci Gabriel la
foire de Chatou c'est jusqu'au 1er
octobre de 10h à 19h et vous attendez
tout le monde les passionnés d'armes et
aussi les simples curieux les passionnés
d'art et les sables curieux qui auront
de toute façon des envies et bien
rendez-vous sur l'île des
Impressionnistes en attendant très belle
soirée sur TV 78